hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday May 21st two thousand and
what is it eighteen 2018 what's going on
um how you doing you doing good oh
that's good that's good
another gloomy gloomy rainy misty day
out here in LA it's been like freezing
you know yeah that's the deal it's just
all I don't know it's like 9 o'clock out
here
9 o'clock that feels like it's [ __ ]
6:00 in the morning over there this is
one of these days that it's like how am
I gonna get anything done
second it's all Claude the Sun man
there's something in the Sun Oh Sun it's
a little bit overcast and that your
internal clock is like hey man well
maybe we should just like lay down and
like do that tomorrow man
how anybody gets anything done in
Seattle is [ __ ] beyond me or San
Francisco for that matter even though I
lucked out with all this great weather
when I was up there but Jesus Christ you
must just get used to it you know if
you're successful in like Seattle you
got to be able to be successful anywhere
right I was speaking of that [ __ ] I was
watching this thing on the 90s right
after my wife was watching she was
watching the Royal Wedding I came back
from San Francisco by the way thank you
to everybody who came out that was an
incredible week I had such a great time
up there and I drank too much so now I'm
back back on the food and the booze
wagon I'm on the elliptical turn it all
around on the road Billy booze bag at
home [ __ ] father O'Malley well that's
probably not a good thing to say huh
Catholic priest
Oh HHI t2 what am I trying to say here
so I come back you know I'm all excited
to see my wife and kid and I come home
and she's watching that Royal Wedding
which was literally the whole [ __ ]
wedding oh my god I felt so bad for that
the [ __ ] guy whoever what is Harry
you can't just get married it's got to
be all of that you know everybody all
dressed up in the crazy hats and [ __ ] it
was like the [ __ ] Kentucky Derby met
meets like medieval Manor it was Jim
Carrey's character in that Cable Guy
movie down down down
Babla going down when he was there at
that [ __ ] you know that theme
restaurant there whatever I'm happy for
both of them they felt loved but they're
together Jesus Christ so she watched the
whole goddamn thing
and so she's upstairs so I was like okay
I'm gonna go unpack downstairs we got a
TV downstairs so I go downstairs and in
the process was me unpacking she came
downstairs cuz she wanted to hang out
with me and and she turned on the
[ __ ] the wedding down there and I
believe I yelled into a thick bathrobe
what did you say I said it's great to be
back with you and me so I walked in
there and I just was like I know I'll
just slowly walk out of the room and I
got all the way out of the room and
closed the door to within two inches and
she was like where you going it's like
gonna go upstairs she's like I wanted to
hang out with you it's like I I can't
watch this
she goes it's almost over so I went
upstairs and you know I don't know I get
her watching that that would be like but
that would that the Royal Wedding would
be like me trying to get her to watch I
don't know some Hall of Fame induction
ceremony after she's been away for five
days you know oh I had a hilarious thing
up for me a promise in San Francisco
right so I mean like an [ __ ] I went
to this Vietnamese restaurant I never
beat nummies food I don't know why I'm a
creature habit I'll eat sushi and I'll
eat like you know Chinese food and I'll
eat Indian food
oh I'll dance all around that continent
but for some reason like Vietnamese food
you know I'm like I don't know about
that
I don't know Thai food I had a long time
ago and I got food poisoning off it so I
wouldn't I can't even for like 10 years
and then also I always get the same
[ __ ] thing cuz the menus just
overwhelming because I don't know what
anything is and I don't want to make a
mistake so I always get the what the
[ __ ] is it called
I don't Nino's what it is it's she cuz
you gotta get this thing again and every
time I get sushi I get the exact same
sushi spicy yellowtail here in roll or
something else and of salmon avocado
it's an edamame right you get the same
thing every time I know I know I do I
realize that I got these things they
work for me I'm afraid to venture into
other parts of the menu you got me right
so I'd never had Vietnamese food so I
was like the whole thing was like like
what is it like what are they gonna it's
always the same [ __ ] beef chicken and
pork and just how they dress it up so my
god so I went in there I got this
chicken sandwich I saw these shredded
carrots on top of it I was like oh my
god that's gonna be gross and I ate it
and it was [ __ ] delicious
so anyways but you know the chicken was
kind of fried I told you ate bet oh hey
Ben
tonight I got the salt going through my
veins and up the street there was an ice
cream place so so this is all off the
rails I wasn't my diet so I'm gonna go
up to the ice-cream place so I [ __ ]
walk in there and it's one of these new
agey ice-cream artisan ice cream
whatever the [ __ ] that means all I know
is when it says artisan if you're an old
guy like me you're not gonna recognize
any of the flavor flavors they had like
some like I was just looking for
chocolate vanilla strawberry the
old-school [ __ ] they don't have any of
that they got like potato chips in it
and [ __ ] they got one was like chocolate
chocolate rose leaf or something if
anybody can tell me what the [ __ ] that
is so I just looked at I was just like
what the [ __ ] is this I wasn't there an
ice cream store around the corner I'll
go to that one maybe that's an
old-school one and I walked into that
one
same [ __ ] they had six flavors I
couldn't I couldn't remember any of them
today if you had a gun to my head
so I say to the lady I just go 18 she
got mint chocolate chip she goes no it's
not in season most likely it is not in
season and she turns around she's like
Megan wait wait mint chocolate chip
gonna be in season
and lake heads up she's like I think she
lied
how [ __ ] ridiculous leads to diabetes
this is poison your body doesn't need
this there's a lot of studies out there
right now that is saying sugar is a
carcinogen you know that's just what the
[ __ ] you're serving people but whoa but
it's fresh this is in season cancer
right so you know what I did I was like
[ __ ] this I just walk out I just said
okay thank you and I walk out right and
you know what I did I just went to the
same place that old people get their ice
cream I went to Walgreens and went to a
pharmacy right now all I got to do is
find wherever the fotomat developing
places and you see about eight old
people there with like instant in stuff
uh kid cameras whatever the hell those
things
used to be and right to the left of it
or to the right of it will be ice cream
and I went there and I walked right in I
saw haagen-dazs mint chocolate chip I
bought a whole [ __ ] pint I didn't
want it you know I just wanted a small
cup so I bought the whole pint that was
so [ __ ] tempted to walk back to that
ice cream store would be like hey ladies
what I didn't and then I went back to
the hotel room and even though I was
good after eating like a third of it
like I didn't have a freezer or anything
was gonna go bad and my mother taught me
not to waste so I plowed through the
whole thing ate a pie of ice cream in
like the middle of the day and my body
was just like in our eye dude this is
what we're doing and I couldn't get out
of bed for like the next [ __ ] three
hours the sugar went through the [ __ ]
roof my unnatural sugar evidently what
season is sugar and what's Co when is
sugar in season is what I should ask so
there you go
all right if you're old and you need ice
cream you want some ice cream at this
point I would suggest going to the
grocery store or going to a pharmacy
drugstore they have the old school
chocolate vanilla strawberry mint
chocolate chip
butter pecan all those old ones okay and
I don't to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] old guy
so I respect the young people and their
new crazy flavors you know where they
take other desserts and they stick it in
there you know what candy bars and
brownies and [ __ ] it's just like it's
it's [ __ ] redundant although I will
smoke a cigar drink some smoky scotch so
I don't know I don't know what anyways I
guess that was my aya you know what's
the deal with ice cream sort of story
speaking of ice because I become friends
with Josh Adam is the host of the
goddamn comedy Jim he's a good friend of
mine he somehow has me rooting for the
[ __ ] Washington Capitals you know
every year in the playoffs right
obviously if they play my
once I don't okay but you know so he can
you know feel what it's like to win a
championship so gonna put a little
sparkle in his eye and now he has me
watching these this [ __ ] team every
year and I was sitting by myself
yesterday you know if you haven't paid
attention to this series the lightning
lost the first two games Capitals won
the first two games and my buddy was all
excited and I said hey I don't want to
be the guy raining on your parade but we
beat him pretty easily in Game one and
then they they just shut us down and ran
the [ __ ] table so I think I'd wait I
was at least up three games to none
before I got excited about beating the
Lightning right so they won the first
two games the capitalist did then the
Lightning won Game three they won Game
four and yesterday I'm sitting down
watching Game five watching this adopted
team that's gonna break your heart every
year and I was by myself I literally
said to the TV you know if the Lightning
scored yet another go exists I just say
[ __ ] capitals if it goddamn [ __ ]
year and that was just like what am I
doing this supporting a friend and then
that's just you know standing in line
for an ass-kicking for no goddamn reason
so and how about those Vegas nights
Jesus Christ making short work or the
Winnipeg Jets what do they got on that
team I know they got the flour from
Pittsburgh between the pipes I guess
he's playing [ __ ] unbelievable they
got a bunch of wily veterans coming
together I don't know I every time I
picture that team it's like it's like an
over 35 league game you know within the
NHL but uh good for that man
it's got to be funny you know the first
year they don't make the finals now
their fans are gonna react to that
they're going to be so goddamn spoiled
in the history of the four major sports
has this ever happened has an expansion
team in their first year ever I can look
this up ever
made it to like the equivalent of the
Super Bowl World Series type of [ __ ]
okay has an expansion team ever made the
finals okay though they're going to say
well the Vegas night study yesterday all
right Vegas become the first expansion
team to reach a championship yep there
you go has an expansion team everyone a
championship well if no one's ever made
the championship game that would be a no
all right is the article expansion teams
not supposed to be good especially in
their first year the fact that these
clubs have to drop players what the [ __ ]
was that I thought that was a bull
sliding off the counter the fact that
these club was an earthquake just in my
kitchen the fact that these clubs have
to drop players who often aren't
important enough to their current teams
to be projected although that's not
necessarily always the case provides
expansion teams with a significant
disadvantage in their inaugural season's
season this however the Vegas goal this
year however the Golden Knights have
dispelled that notion on their way to a
Stanley Cup final appearance oh this is
the big thing every year it's just
Stanley Cup final and it's the NBA
Finals and it's all how you look at if
you look at all seven games collectively
as the final or if you look at each game
this is this is an NBA final game this
is Game one of the NBA
I don't know I think the way the cocky
does it makes a little more sense
how does Vegas stack up against the
other expansion teams all right here we
go in the NHL the Golden Knights are
just the second team since 1950 to
appear in the final in its inaugural
season joining the st. Louis Blues in
1968 all that out that's [ __ ] though
before I even read the next sentence
because I remember you know what they
did in the NHL okay they went from six
teams to 12 teams and rather than put in
three with the three original in one
conference and three with the three
originally others they have the entire
expansion six in their own conference
from day one one of them was going to
make it there and then get [ __ ] swept
by one of the original six right what
does it say
however the Blues were one of six
expansion teams that year and all six of
them were placed in the same division
the winner which advanced to the final
there you go in MLS the Chicago Fire
shocked the world world world in 1998 by
winning the MLS Cup and US Open Cup in
their first season I would say they shot
the [ __ ] the United States Soccer
world I wouldn't say they shocked the
world but the rest of the world does
watch soccer or as they call it football
but I don't think they respect our
[ __ ] right probably made us look
worse right but in the made in Major
League Baseball no expansion Club has
finished with more than 70 wins in its
first season's season in the NBA this
1916 Chicago Bulls are the most success
expect successful expansion team Jesus
Christ but only won 33 games and in the
NFL the 1995 Carolina Panthers who
finished just 7 and 9 topped the list
well there you go there you go man
after discipline
career Tampa Bret Conolly redeems
himself as a capital there's that next
capital game tonight is that what you're
telling me
yeah it's three games to two 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time Oh in the Boston Celtics
Jesus Christ this series is so [ __ ]
long they played the first two games and
it was like a nine day layoff which I
think helped toll Cleveland I would say
a bunch of my buddies were all excited
like dude I think the shelter's you're
gonna win it [ __ ] five they're gonna
sweep them and I'm just like I don't
know I was just like they they need to
win Game three because if they lose Game
three then it's two to one and then all
of a sudden Cleveland can tie it up and
that's the plastinated thing about a
seven-game series like if you're three
games to one you like dough were in the
driver's seat the second you lose Game
five the rest of the series six and
seven the pressures on you can they
close him out can they [ __ ] close
them out so I was joking with the buddy
mine who is a cavalier fan he said you
know before Game three saying you guys
look great and I said I won't be
comfortable till we get that fourth win
against you guys and once again you saw
what made LeBron [ __ ] so great
because he did in that game what a lot
of people with half his skill won't do
which is past the [ __ ] ball and he
got all these [ __ ] teammates involved
and anybody could draw that up on paper
but this guy actually goes out and does
it and you know so now we got the great
Brad Stevens he's got to figure out a
way to come up with some sort of defense
if if that's what LeBron is going to do
but uh this series is far from over
either way and I'm gonna die another
thousand deaths tonight watching the
goddamn game drives me [ __ ] nuts man
it drives me nuts sometimes you ever get
like jealous to somebody like as much as
like the Cleveland sports fans like the
Cleveland Browns fans
like [ __ ] moan and complain about never
won in a Super Bowl or anything like
that it's just like you know there's no
surprise then you're not aging watching
them suck you just like a dick [ __ ]
suck blob of blood it's over it's
hopeless but if you have a team that
makes the playoffs they give you hope
and you [ __ ] book every time they get
that you [ __ ] believe it and you get
all excited as much as the Celtics
people would say have tremendously over
achieved if they lose this series it's
gonna be devastating and I always get as
I've gotten older I always just think to
myself why do I give a [ __ ] why do I
give a [ __ ] like that the stuff I have
to do when the game is on like where I
have to go mentally so I could just
handle sitting there like I don't get
how people who just [ __ ] sit there
and watch it I have to go into the other
room you know I got to start paying
bills and stuff while I'm watching again
I have to have another activity so I'm
just not sitting there watching the
[ __ ] game lose in my mind but anyways
you know as much as that we got our
asses whipped in Game three you know I
can't get mad at greatness and that's
what I think you saw with the brunt so
who knows Celtics obviously if they went
tonight we'd be up three games to one we
shall see what happens and I'm gonna
watch my surrogate [ __ ] capitals
tonight we'll see what happens well no
wait I'm gonna watch the Celtics I'll be
flipping back and forth the [ __ ]
lightning man they just give me the old
right there for it what they score 17
seconds into that game there you go BAM
the [ __ ] knock a goalie right out of
the game before you even get you goddamn
first beer they got a bunch of snipers
all right let me read a little bit of
advertisement for
for this week anyways but this is my
deal is my last big pusher as I slide
into my [ __ ] 50th birthday here where
you know I got myself a great shape but
I think I'd peaked too early then I had
that bad week in San Francisco so now we
got to have a perfect week just to just
to get even with what the [ __ ] I did
last week and but I think I'll be all
right you know coming right around 170
look alright
you know at least when I cry one of my
40s are over and I look down on my
stomach it won't be as big and that'll
be uplifting does that make sense
I [ __ ] all right zip recruiter are
you hiring well are you posting your
position to job sites and waiting and
waiting for the right people to see it
what do you do while you're waiting
zip knew there was a smarter way so they
built a platform that finds the right
job candidates just for you old zip
[Applause]
Loren's what you were looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job these invitations have
revolutionized how you find your next
hire in fact 80% of employees who post a
job on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day and said recruiter doesn't stop
there
they even spot like the strongest
applications you received so you never
miss a great match what if somebody's
lying on their resume sorry I just
didn't want to bring up the fly in the
ointment the right candidates are out
there old it's how you find them
businesses of all sizes trust it
recruiter for their hiring needs right
now my listeners can try zip for free
that's right just go to zip recruit comp
size per that zip recruit comm / / one
more time hi chip
the smartest way to hire all right so
anyways all freckles old freckles Oh
freckles laying off the [ __ ] booze
doodoo doodoo for [ __ ] hoes for freckles
I'm actually seriously considering
getting rid of my bar can you put like
half drank [ __ ] is that sounds like the
beginning of like a movie ripping off
said Eddie Murphy movie Axel Foley what
do you think was playing other than the
original porn it's actually a highlight
for the Vegas nights Vegas will be that
will play the winner of the capital
series si that's on Sports Illustrated
if you'd like to have that as a ringtone
but do do let's see what this one sounds
like
[Music]
oh this is the old guy chasing the woman
to the train I saw this woman she was
beautiful she was beautiful I had to
talk to her like you could do that in
[ __ ] real life see some woman on a
platform and then start running towards
her train you know how do you not come
off as a creep you can't even be walking
briskly I would think that alone would
freak a woman up like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing
[Laughter]
you don't ever want a stranger walking
briskly towards you anyway so I mean
that's just my opinion
it's just my opinion people that's all
this [ __ ] podcast is it's just my
opinion over and over and over again for
60 goddamn minutes and you just got to
sit there and take oh you shut it off
you know that's always an option you
could do that instead of sitting there
playing the victim you know and writing
a blog about it
I was so mentally abused by the Monday
morning podcast I couldn't reach up and
hit stop all right so I've been
downloading a bunch of [ __ ] like late
70s and early 80s let's talk music here
I was watching something what's-his-face
there the lead singer he was in black
fat Flagg whoops Jesus Christ didn't
need to say that Black Flag the [ __ ] is
his name there he had a band he had a
band named after him ah Jesus Christ
dude my brain is so [ __ ] fried
I keep thinking Ronson like Mark Ronson
I know it's not that but the [ __ ] is
this god damn and I gotta look this [ __ ]
up don't [ __ ] laugh at me cuz I know
I know I'm not the only one who does
this [ __ ]
Black Flag lead singer thought this is
why I could never be on Jeopardy cuz
even I want to know the [ __ ] answers
even when I know the goddamn answers
Henry Rollins jesus [ __ ] christ so I
saw this thing Henry Rollins right and
he was recommending these albums some of
them I had some of them I didn't and so
he recommended this band Joy Division
and it's like alright I've heard of this
band for [ __ ] ever I never took the
time to get into him or any of that [ __ ]
if this guy's saying this is the real
[ __ ] he was saying their original album
is as good as anything the Rolling
Stones ever did and blah blah blah blah
so I went out I went right to iTunes and
promptly downloaded their second album
by accident I gotta tell you I loved it
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go back I kind of
feel [ __ ] up because I should have
done it chronologically and seeing the
growth even though they went around that
long because unfortunately the lead
singer committed suicide barely 24 years
old but Jesus Christ there's some
[ __ ] unbelievable bands that came out
of Manchester in the late 70s and early
early 80s that was so goddamn different
from everything else that was going on
considering that first album that I
haven't listened to yet if it sounds
anything like the second album
Achaemenid
to listen to that music and know that
like popular music was like at the time
was like I love that I wanna put on my
boogie shoes and hey [ __ ] lady let's
go create some herpes
Payne if that's what all those sons were
we're gonna stop [ __ ] until you can
die from this [ __ ] being it GU dude come
on now
coco cocaine is not addictive being it
alright sorry anyways but you know
what's funny I like disco music - I like
to [ __ ] because I was too young to know
that it that evidently everybody [ __ ]
hated it and when I hear that [ __ ] you
know boot up it boom that but we did I
just Paul you can't tell by the way I
[ __ ] a band Oh daddy joke I just
pictured myself riding my bicycle up to
the store to buy some football cards at
baseball cards
alright I didn't know any better I
didn't realize that that was the music
of the man I had no idea
YMCA I thought all of that [ __ ] was like
I thought that was legit no idea anyways
check out Joy Division download their
first album like Henry Rollins said
don't [ __ ] accidentally download the
second one and then defend disco like I
just did on my podcast okay you don't
have to so I was listening to that and
then I was listening to that led me to
remember Romeo void Never Say Never
I never knew what the woman looked like
or anybody in the band one of the
coolest look at bands you're ever gonna
see and that once again way ahead of
their [ __ ] time the video for Never
Say Never is cool it's like a [ __ ]
movie and I know I used to watch MTV all
the time I barely remember them ever
playing this but I would say Romeo void
and Joy Division both of them me
listening to them really sitting down
listening to that [ __ ] for the first
time in 2018 and the music still holds
up it doesn't feel like you know what
are some of the popular [ __ ] I'll fight
that well dad bout where yo we're good
that's not a bad song either right you
know something you can't you can't
objectively look at any music that was
out when you were growing up you don't
mean because there was like oh man I
mean when this song came on that's the
first time I got hung on a door knob by
my underwear by the upperclassmen like
you got all these gear all these great
childhood [ __ ] memories I remember
that that's that time that [ __ ]
teacher locked me in the closet because
he had to go do something he didn't have
time to like [ __ ] you know watch me
during detention I remember that I
remember that date that was a day that
[ __ ] I wanna get in all this [ __ ] um
anyways check him out if you get a
chance I guess that was the point of all
that the point of all that was to check
to check those people out if you have if
you have time if you don't I understand
just keep listening to this [ __ ] you
listen to you know I kind of noticed
that when uh when I went to that Giants
baseball game last week like there was a
couple of guys that came to the plate
and they would just listen this remember
that nu-metal and some of that horrific
[ __ ] that came out in the early 2000s
you know when they tried to combine rap
and metal you know and there's everybody
be up there playing instruments and then
that'd be that one white kid running it
around you like oh god is he gonna start
rapping please God don't don't let him
stop rapping that is the one amazing
thing about that style of music that was
the one style of music that white people
as much as they tried just could not
steal it you know I'm not saying that
they're you know Eminem and some guys
like that ever been tremendous but you
know that is one it was just I don't
know what it was you just white people
did their best that man that was that
whole jet and the music was so good that
that white kids got into it and then
they did hey man we ought to put
our band but better that better day yo
just did work it just didn't work there
was a lot of stuff from that time they
just [ __ ] didn't work
I remember slam poetry oh my god
Jesus Christ that that was just like I
just remembered the person who would
ever be doing it would always have their
eyebrows up and be like pointing at you
like what they were saying was just
[ __ ] unbelievable like just
unbelievable and I was like blowing your
mind and I would just be sitting there
going like that you know it's kind of a
very mainstream point of view that has
been said about people in power for a
long time I guess I've never heard it
rhymed before so that makes it new I
don't know but I could look at it
objectively because that was yet another
time stand-up comedians were going like
oh my god this just got to take over the
state of comedy we're all gonna be
[ __ ] homeless right I told you guys
about that time when in Massachusetts
anyways do you member karaoke they still
have karaoke right which I know a lot of
bands were nervous that that was going
to end people going to see live music
you know cuz some plumber was gonna be
staying on stage go on like people at
that point would be like you know I
don't think I need to see this
generations Freddie Mercury because I
can watch the guy who just plumbed my
[ __ ] toilet sink journey at this
point Thank You karaoke but you know you
know it is GP you live in fear it's what
it is people live in fear so anyways the
there was something that came out was
called Carrie jokey and basically people
in the restaurant or whatever would go
onstage and there'd be a teleprompter
and they would just read a joke like you
know two guys walk into a bar and the
bartender says daba daba d4 blah blah
blah blah blah hey I didn't know then I
would have [ __ ] unit an hour ago and
then they couldn't teach timing right
but we were all convinced like do carry
jokey it's gonna do two stand-up comedy
what karaoke did two live music which
was absolutely nothing unless you were
in an incredibly shitty band so one time
we were I know I've told this story
before this is for the new listeners
alright so one time I was doing this gig
somewhere in New Hampshire was upstairs
at a bar it's a two storey bar okay
people take drinking seriously in New
England two storey [ __ ] bar you know
and there was plenty of room to add on
to the bar it wasn't like you know it
was just densely populated area I don't
know this guy was just building up for
whatever reason so we're on the second
story of this [ __ ] building and
across the street is this little
carnival and all I remember was you know
that you know that Viking ship ride
again it's just basically it's like a
giant swing going back and forth but
you're on that giant boat so that is
basically right outside the windows on
the second floor of this bar and there
was screen windows too because it was
the summer and I guess this place must
not have had air conditioning and all I
remember was standing on stage bombing
and all I could hear was the people
screaming on the ride so my set they
turned into like my own little horror
film and what was funny was the boat was
not like parallel to the bar it was like
pointed at it and it looked like it was
going to come right through the [ __ ]
window and then it would go up I
remember the guy I was looking at was
saying you know it's very phallic
looking right and I was dying laughing
because when the underneath the boat was
coming up and going back it looked like
you know that ridiculous shot in porno
we're just in case you'd think he's
not putting it in there they make she
couldn't goddamn well you know that
that's what's happening I always wonder
if like the porn star can feel the heat
of the lens unlike their ball bags and
[ __ ] who has you know maybe that's
why they shaved their pubes because they
got sick of him lighting on fire during
takes I don't know I've never really
seen it behind this actually I did see a
behind the scenes of a porno recently of
a performer porn star of this guy
getting into the world and then wanting
to get out of it and staying in it for
20 [ __ ] years and I watched the whole
thing right up until when he decided to
get out of it and then the next one was
him at Bible study and then I shut it
off you know I was just like I don't
want to watch this part you know
reminding me that I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and I should probably you know look at
Bible studying or something I don't know
what the [ __ ] is this just something
always wakes me out about that you know
I mean cuz even gets it today hey man
like that stuff doesn't exist man you
also think hey well what does it what
does exist these are the ramblings of a
guy turn to 50 going like do I need to
hedge my bets to start going back to
church
but wouldn't a higher power know like
this guy's not totally buying into this
[ __ ] what is he doing right now is he
practicing some sort of sticking pattern
on the church pews when he plays drums
later on today that's not very
respectful alright let's let's do some
reeds here for this week grass fed verse
grass finished dear Billy beef breath
releasing on your podcast you did an ad
for your new sponsor butcher box by the
way I
I tried that that pork that they said
swine that they sent me and it was you
know I didn't realize like the original
pigs that came over here before I guess
they were all mixed with these other
pigs it's very like white supremacy the
way they have like the pigs and dogs
like purebred and all that well these
purebred pigs like you got it you got to
prove through their DNA that these are
actually you know
I don't know what takes from [ __ ]
Liverpool I have no idea all I can tell
is that you know I bought into the hype
so I don't know if that affected my
taste buds but it was one of the best
porkchops I've ever had in my life so
hats off to butcher box anyways he said
you didn't know what the term
grass-finished beef means it means they
are giving you the real thing a lot of
restaurants these they tell you they
serve grass-fed beef and they usually
charge more for it the term used to mean
exactly what it sounds like but it's all
gotten watered down now down and now
it's often just a marketing gimmick
pretty much all cattle are grass-fed
they are fred grass pellets hey or if
they are lucky they get to spend their
lives happily grazing in a pasture but
then almost almost all of them get fed
grain or other garbage to fatten them up
at the feedlot before slaughter
grass-finished however means they eat
grass right up until the very end I
learned this little bit of trivia when I
was working as a travel writer in Hawaii
I wanted to pass it along because I
figure I owe you that's pretty cool I
started listening a podcast in Joe
Rogan's podcast because I frequently had
long drives by myself to get to remote
areas of the various islands and persons
can only listen to so much and a person
can only listen is so much Hawaiian
music that's hilarious thanks for
keeping me company long drives no
problem in case you've never been to
Hawaii before and are questioning my
comment about long drive the Big Island
is about the size of the state of
Connecticut I didn't know that and since
there are no direct routes it takes more
than two hours to get from the Kona side
of the Big Island to the high/low side
where the volcano is currently erupting
you know the bright side of that volcano
erupting is isn't it creating more land
you know well you know thinning out the
population evidently here's a link about
the term grass fed so you can verify for
yourself but it's a long article so
probably not something you want to read
on the podcast do it if it's a short
article it's not something
I read on the podcast God knows I'll
[ __ ] that up
how scary still not only live next to a
[ __ ] volcano but to be like on a
goddamn Island I mean I don't you know
the only thing that I've seen that has
been knots knots like a little more
relaxing is how slow lava the lavas been
moving you know after it's sort of a
rough so at ease don't be near it well
you know spitting up like a [ __ ]
toddler right let me see let me read up
on this [ __ ] Hawaii volcano what is the
latest
why volcano warning of toxic gas plumes
lava spews Lai's of toxic gas and glass
into the air it's spewing glass that
people throw their [ __ ] soda pop
bottles down there or is that some
chemically way that all of those
minerals with that level of heat turns
into glass lava acid rain fog sulfur
dioxide and now lays new deadly threat
emerges good [ __ ] Lord can you
imagine if you're there right now in
your honeymoon you can't tell me that's
not an omen did I marry the right person
God give me a sign that could mean you
know like actually mean a good thing
right
put the eruption you know it's gonna
[ __ ] your brains out I don't I don't
pretend to know okay first it was lava
then acid rain and vog what the [ __ ] is
vog am i so far behind the stories
people know what vlog is vlog vlog is a
form of air pollution that results when
sulfur dioxide and other gases and
particles emitted by an erupting volcano
react with oxygen and moisture in the
presence of sunlight the word is a poor
man tow tow man tow port man to
of the word volcanic smog and fog
you mean the smoke that comes out of a
volcano they call that vog the term is
common in the Hawaiian Islands all right
fog is created when volcanic gases react
with sunlight oxygen and moisture the
result includes sulfur sulfuric acid and
other self jesus-fucking-christ
those poor people in living that goddamn
paradise just sitting there you know so
like school gets canceled out there
there will be no school today due to the
vog we got to go in next to two weeks in
June because we missed those two weeks
you know three months earlier when the
volcano was erupting
it's [ __ ] a wine people a tough huh
oh there we get a little snowstorm it's
gonna be you could slip and fall and
break your tailbone then on the other
side that's it they go oh really
now we could burn to death be vaporized
right you go outside breathe in poison
so what the [ __ ] what is everybody doing
out like how poisonous is it Jesus
Christ can you imagine that [ __ ] like
you still decide to go ahead with your
vacation and as you're coming in for a
landing you're seeing all that vlog
honey honey it's okay stop crying stop
crying we're on the other side of the
island okay
it's just honey it's just lava okay it's
just lava and a little bit of poison gas
and and it's it's currently still
happening other than that I mean it's
gonna be fine you're gonna be sitting on
the beach with with with a lei around
your neck and a gas mask on your face
taking a big gulp of oxygen before you
lift the mask and take a sip off your
straw drinking out of a coconut just
like we planned
come on this is our time come on we're
gonna start a family
don't ruin first they couldn't find my
shoes and our volcanoes are rocking I
just want to go home all right
egg stay strong Hawaii I don't know what
else you do I always saw well ya know if
you near the ocean the lava comes you
just [ __ ] just stand in the ocean then
the sharks come and get you right then
it's just no way to [ __ ] do it
I don't we literally stay out of the
ocean I be like I mean like [ __ ] you
know stand along the beach frolic in the
waves as you watch your retirement fun
in your house burn up in flames did
anybody else see that footage of that
lava just kind of going across the
street right towards that white car then
it bug you that nobody said can't get
the [ __ ] car out of there Jesus
Christ I'll tell you right now if you
ever steal a car and you want to get rid
of it that's it
steal a car well a volcano was erupting
have you a little Joyride right the cops
chase you just drive it into some lava
and then you [ __ ] jump out then you
know what happened was they would have
the dashboard cam and then they'd get
you for [ __ ] I don't know destroying
evidence source I don't know what the
[ __ ] who knows I don't pretend to
understand things
all right improve your franch dear Billy
bilingual I'm a 24 year old American man
who completed a year abroad in Paris I
knew no French before going and now I'm
now fluent yeah well that's the way to
do it you're over there I know you've
been using rosetta stone and that's
really helpful but here's a tip on how
you can become conversationally fluent
fluent oh great the best thing to do is
listen to the audiobook and read this
text simultaneously in French I know you
hate reading but if you get a good
narrator it can be entertaining and will
make you literate oh yeah I've been
I've been reading French books like kids
books to my daughter I read Harry Potter
and the coldest saucer is whatever and I
was able to chat up French women
afterwards
hope this helps and go [ __ ] yourself
well wait a minute if someone's just
speaking French and nobody's translating
it for me I'm just listening to French
how does it work
audiobook and read the text
simultaneously let me see something
French
audio book with a Veck text let's see
what I got here
French parallel audio Wow look at that
you know what I'm gonna do it I'll give
it a shot
thank you very much thank you very much
oh Jesus look at this one oh Jesus
police caught me with the prostitute
what's up bill a big fan of yours I
enjoy your all I enjoy your all your
stand-ups okay I'm gonna say this is a
first draft your Netflix originals
especially efforts for family thank you
and your interviews on YouTube mostly
the ones on Conan I'm 28 years old
single no kids live alone kind of a
loner I smoke weed I work midnight at a
gas station alright let's do this again
28 years old single no kids I live alone
kind of a loner I smoke weed I work
midnight at a gas station I never go out
I don't drink I don't do any kind of
clubs or hardcore drugs I just get horny
I usually have girls but not this time I
[ __ ] it up with every girl I was
talking to somehow I managed to be rude
by asking them if they enjoyed giving
head oh boy
I gotta say man I got caught up in some
[ __ ] tomorrow I have a trial and I'm
a little nervous I have to get a
court-appointed attorney I don't trust
anyone though the lawyer I was supposed
to have wouldn't stop asking me for
money when I told her I have it in three
days I don't lie I'm honest as [ __ ] all
right I always getting over some people
say I don't lie anybody knows me knows I
tell the truth
I didn't do that all right so basically
what happened I got pulled over by the
cops telling me straight up they saw me
talking with a known prostitute for sure
it was a sting operation even though she
showed me her tits she was cute too cute
if he asked me a little too cute so she
got in my car and asked me what I wanted
I told her but she wanted more money so
I said no thanks she got out and I
decided to go home I pull out into the
street and literally not even 30 seconds
later I see lights come on behind me
luckily I didn't go to jail they gave me
a ticket and impounded my car though all
right so what's the problem
I've been bullshitting my mom I told her
the cars in the shop I thought you said
you don't lie and that you're honest as
[ __ ] anyways I had to spend 2 grand to
get it back but it was in my mom's name
so I had to come up with another lie I
thought you said you didn't lie you're
honest is [ __ ] and I was trying to sell
the car even though that makes no
[ __ ] sense what so I needed paperwork
stating she was my mother giving me
permission to retrieve my car from the
County Clerk's office and have it
notarized by the bank I know bill I
don't lie if I told my mom she this she
probably died all right we kind of
covered his tracks a no-joke I'm the
youngest of five all fuck-ups all boys
I'm supposed to be the good one and I am
I was just being stupid I think the only
thing that's worrying me is the fine
probably like 5 to 10 grand oh well
thanks for the time to read this by the
way I live I'm exhale you live I have
tickets to your show I can't wait
anyways thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
all right well
she's probably gonna find out I would
just tell her I just tell to say listen
I [ __ ] up
you know I [ __ ] up she's your mother
she'll forgive you right I don't know I
think I would be more worried about the
five to ten thousand dollar fine than
your mom not loving you anymore all
right you [ __ ] up you made a mistake
everybody makes mistakes I make mistakes
you made a mistake you know what the
[ __ ] life is you make mistakes you
learn from your mistakes you move on you
try to do better all right that's it
I've said it for a long time if people
were cars we'd be recalled there's a
reason the world is so [ __ ] up it's
because humans are running it okay we're
just smart enough to be [ __ ] morons
all right good luck to you my friend's
dad wants to pay me to get naked jesus
[ __ ] christ
okay well the last one girlfriend and
best friends graduating same time
different places thank you a nice sitcom
trope I can finish with here I got two
dates all right let's get through this
one Mike debt my friend's dad wants to
pay me to get naked oh Jesus hey mr.
William Frederick burp I hope you're
doing good big fan of the podcast and
all your other [ __ ] keep doing what
you're doing I'm a 24 year old guy from
the UK okay the UK until recently I've
been working behind the bar in the local
pub where my friend's dad would drink
regularly I met him a handful of times
over the past 10 years or so as his son
as his son is one of my best friends
he's about 70 years old and a very
devout Catholic that's not a good
characteristic who has also worked at
the church in some other capacity or
another I shouldn't blame the whole
religion okay because maybe he's a good
guy
all right I've always got a weird vibe
from him oh boy and he started to seem
even weirder of Jesus after seeing him
multiple times in a week he was given
big tips which is rare in the UK and he
would cut my hand with both hands for 10
seconds or so when he gave them money to
me he'd stare into my eyes saying all
this weird complimentary stuff about me
like you're a very good ball man
and you'll go fall sorry at the bad
accent so I started to feel something
was off about this guy yeah yeah this is
like when Quint slid into the mouth of
the shark
one day after a month a few months of
generous tips from him and general weird
encounters he had about five large
glasses of red wine and got pretty drunk
as I was walking around the pub
collecting glasses he called me over to
him and pulled me to one side in a dark
dimly lit corner he hushed his voice and
got really close to me with his putrid
breath wafting into my nose and said
something along the lines of Roy I have
a proposition for you first off I just
want to make it clear that I'm not gay
of Jesus I'm not gay at all right well I
want to do but I do have what I do have
is an appreciation of for the male form
I can't keep doing this accent what I do
have is an appreciation for the male
form I used to have a boy who I would
pay 150 pounds which is to run our euros
that's our 203 American really to allow
me to look at his naked body a few times
per week I wouldn't touch him or force
him to do anything he would simply get
undress and I would appreciate his body
and pay him for his time does this sound
like something you would be interested
in oh my god I immediately said no it
was pretty shocked but I didn't make a
scene I just laughed it off and said
sorry I'm not interested the next day he
came into the pub and practically begged
me not to tell his son and started to
give me even bigger tips and the
following weeks I tried to refuse but
insisted it was basically hush money it
was like I was wrapped up in some sort
of big scandal and being paid for my
silence there was one time where he ran
into the pub looking really flustered
during a storm but little hair he has
left was all over the place and was
stuck to his head to his red wet veiny
face Jesus Christ his clothes were
drenched he was really out of breath and
he ran out to me and said you haven't
told him have you that's [ __ ] nuts
because the person was probably acting
weird or slightly different I haven't
told him no I said he was clearly really
worried about what he'd said so I
couldn't help but feel a little sorry
for him as he's clearly gay and most
likely suppressed it his entire life due
to him being a devout Catholic that's
what I was thinking I feel bad for that
I felt you know obviously that you had
to [ __ ] have that [ __ ] interaction
but I mean yeah that's what this is is
why she just let people be who the [ __ ]
they are my gut instinct is to just
never mention it to anyone but a second
opinion would be great yeah dude I
wouldn't say and he's 70 [ __ ] years
old
alright you know to his credit he asked
you said no and then that was it and now
he's just saying please don't tell
anybody anyway so essentially I know
that one of my best friend's dad is
trying to cheat on his mom with young
men so part of me feels like his wife
has the right to know but on the other
hand I don't want to ruin their family
so my question to you is should I bring
it up with my friend what should I do
Thanks and go [ __ ] yourself but instead
just have a nice thanks and don't go
[ __ ] yourself but instead just have a
nice day for me will you all right sing
love to yourself nyan the little baby
thank you looking forward to the new
officers family thank you now the guys
[ __ ] seven years old I mean what are
you gonna do at that point you know
I don't know as a guy bisexual I have no
[ __ ] idea all I know is he asked you
said no and he's left you alone other
than panicking that you're gonna [ __ ]
tell somebody so I feel like that's his
if he wants to tell people that's his
that's his thing you know what I mean I
don't [ __ ] know follow you I mean I
would think that his wife on some level
might even [ __ ] know who the [ __ ] now
he relationships are very complex - just
[ __ ] jump in there and think that
you're gonna be playing the hero when
you don't have any of the information I
would just just walk away from it just
walk away that's what I would do
personally you know Jesus Christ what a
story felt I was watching a movie all
right girlfriend had best friend
graduating same time different places
dear Billy bombshell my best friend and
new girlfriend are graduating college on
the same day and I don't know whose
ceremony to attend I just finished my
junior year of college and really
started dating a girl one year older who
was graduating in less than a week
however my best friend since I was 5
also graduating college on the same day
at the same time but at a different
school needless to say I could not be in
both places at once I'm not really sure
whose ceremony I should attend I don't
want to piss off my new girlfriend
especially because she's way too hot for
me well if she's way too hot for you
that's a good thing to try to like keep
yourself level because don't [ __ ]
jump every time she asks you to I don't
go to my buddy's graduation to say
unfortunately you know if they just came
at the same time you know what's funny
is it one would be like and you're gonna
choose
like and I would never do that I was
dating a girl for a year and she's like
listen your graduation is the same day
as my best friend since I was five
before she even got through of it I died
listen I get it no [ __ ] problem hey
here's a little secret I don't want to
go to the graduation ceremony myself I
just got to get the piece of goddamn
paper that's killing reason why I'm
showing up don't worry I'll take a video
all right
give us a [ __ ] it's just it's a ceremony
he says I think we're really not sure I
can justify picking a new girlfriend
over my best friend but at the same time
he doesn't give me sex so there's that
aspect let me know what I think should
do I don't think you should operate from
a place of fear I think you should go
with loyalty and you should go to your
friends thing that's what I would do you
know if she can't understand it what are
you gonna do plenty of fish in the sea
all right false rape allegations ruining
my friend's life jesus [ __ ] christ I
hate reading these things because I
don't have any of the information now
you gonna tell me it's a false rape
thing so now I don't know if I'm
actually gonna be supporting a victim or
if I'm gonna be [ __ ] supporting
somebody really did something there's a
situation I'm currently my senior at
college my graduate I think I'm not
reading this [ __ ] thing I'm not
reading this [ __ ] thing all right
look at this psycho [ __ ] got mad and
blah blah now this is all like this is
what's wrong with the internet right now
is because now I'm gonna listen to one
side of the [ __ ] story the woman who
you call a psycho [ __ ] is not going to
get a chance to tell her side of the
story and I'm gonna make a snap judgment
and say yeah you know this is a psycho
[ __ ] I just you know I like these are
like the questions used to be a lot
lighter people
this is some heavy [ __ ] [ __ ] my dad's
my best friend's dad is 70 and I found
out he's gay should I tell them or
should I keep this secret
what the what point did I become
qualified to answer this [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] know anyways that's the podcast
go Celtics go capital
and go [ __ ] yourself I'll talk to you on
Thursday I'll check in on you